let's get into that first story
you know when i first saw this this
morning the story about them leaking
text messages i got really angry because
i am disgusted by these establishment
shills these disgusting vile creatures
of congress they're they're they're
cannibalistic humanoid underground
dwellers who have lurched up from the
underground crawled into congress and we
just sit back and we're like yeah i
guess we'll keep voting for these people
but hopefully now people are waking up
and they will vote out all of these
people especially people like liz cheney
and the story from the independent
donald trump jr sent desperate texts to
mark meadows during capital right urging
trump to take action he has to lead now
revelation of texts come as committee
votes to support contempt of congress
charge for former chief of staff
did i say these people are absolutely
violent disgusting because i'll just
keep saying it
now
that being said the release of these
texts
donald trump jr was urging mark meadows
to get his dad to condemn the riot at
the capitol
sounds like they did not want it to
happen sounds like all of these people
in trump's inner circle were like yo
stop this and then trump came out and
issued a statement saying that it was
wrong and to go home go home peacefully
so they just effectively debunk their
whole narrative if that's the case why
should any of this continue
total clown show i mean in a moral
civilization in moral america
liz cheney would be shunned from society
i see her picture on the screen there um
as a foreign policy guy i i can tell you
all the all the wars she supported all
the military armament uh for the
military industrial complex for for all
of these special interests liz cheney
has the worst of the worst record and
the idea that she's like playing along
it shows that there's really there
there's two parties in america there's
the uniparty represented by liz cheney
um she is a member in good standing
unfortunately most of the establishment
republicans and people in charge are
also part of that unit party and then
you have nancy pelosi and this january
6th committee is
utterly utterly ridiculous and the fact
that she's like supposed to be like the
republican side making it authentic it's
absurd they're like bipartisan support
for you know uh contempt of congress or
whatever
the text messages don't really prove an
insurrection more but everyone kind of
panicking be like this is bad this is
bad this is bad so it's just absurd to
see them still complaining because this
obviously disproves everything that they
were talking about they claimed that
this was orchestrated this was all
planned they tried to take
obviously through the text messages this
is not true we're also learning today
that a dc that the dc attorney general
is going to be is going to be suing the
proud boys and oath keepers because of
the january 6th attack so to me this is
all about just the total dominance of
political power in the establishment to
keep it with themselves and to make sure
that of course trump doesn't have any
political power going forward in the
next election there's also going to be
local elections and i think they're just
kind of fishing for whatever they could
get so they could hit the other side the
other side isn't just as as good again
it's all about power it's all about
authority and they're trying to
consolidate as much of it as they can
and it's absolutely authoritarian than
it is investigative at all if we're
going to investigate somebody why not
get the text messages of you know mr
epstein or glenn maxwell let's release
that to the general public or the videos
or the footage that the fbi is holding
to themselves i would want to know that
i don't care what these people are doing
freaking out you know the worst i think
the worst person in in congress probably
is probably mitch mcconnell
absolutely and then um the reason i say
that over like nancy pelosi or whatever
it's like nancy pelosi's overt you know
what what is it saying the better the
devil you know yep like when nancy
pelosi comes out and she's like oh and
her teeth are falling out and she rips
up trump's speech i'm like i can see the
disdain i can see the the vile behavior
mitch mcconnell just like sticks his
head in his shell and then does nothing
but people vote for him and then you
expect to get some kind of resistance
what the democrats are doing but he's
effectively standing in the way of
regular americans as the democrats you
know go and do their their crackpot
garbage i think the i don't i don't
remember who said this but they said
that
the the the republicans are the
washington generals to the democrats
harlem globetrotters absolutely and it's
all faked it's all rigged it's all like
a world wrestling entertainment i
tweeted a photo today of mitch mcconnell
elbow bumping nancy pelosi
and the caption read if uh effing the
poor people was a handshake this would
be it and that's absolutely what they're
doing they're screwing over hard-working
average americans who are just trying to
live their lives and they're they're
playing this theater this show to try to
convince you that the other side is the
lesser of two evils meanwhile they're
working together in collusion they're
two heads of the same snake and they are
a den of vipers they are sinister
reptilian-like beings that are
cold-blooded and don't give a damn about
you or your friends or your family or
the future of this country they're
selling this country to the highest
bidder and if you're getting screwed
that's all figurative of course do you
think it's the people or the positions
that turn the people into those things i
think it's a combination of both and it
also depends on the individual for for
example henry kissinger i think he's a
corrupt personal sociopathic crazy
person that just thrives off of creating
policies that create human misery for
the benefit of his friends that's my
personal perspective and opinion other
people i believe were entangled in the
system came into the system and they
were told fix the system from the inside
make it better you could fix it just by
being a part of it but you just have to
sell out on this small issue and then
this small issue and then this small
issue and then they get them hanging out
with mr epstein they get the videotapes
of them and then bada bing bada boom
they got them in their pockets a part of
the larger extortion operation and now
they're coming to them saying hey we
need this unpopular bill passed that's
going to screw over your constituency
you're going to have to pass it or we're
going to release the dirt that we have
on you and and that's essentially
washington dc politics that we're seeing
unfold right now and a part of why so
many unpopular uh policies get passed
that's one example of it the other is
just sociopathic individuals the most
amount of sociopaths are located per
capita in washington dc for specific
reasons what's that uh part of the brain
where they say that sociopaths have like
an underdeveloped or small amygdala
i wonder if we could do like is there
like a like a
cat scan or an mri you can do on like
members of congress to make sure and be
like hey look at that they're all psycho
and drug test them i want drug tests on
all members of congress all right i want
term limits i want all the restrictions
they put on the general public put on
them but who votes on that that's the
problem is that they need to vote for
restrictions on themselves yes yeah
they're not going to do it
you know you know it's like this would
actually be like a great sketch it's
like you get some principled politician
maybe like a rand paul or something and
he's like i've got a new bill that says
you know we're we're all going to have
to undergo drug testing and anything we
pass the american people and then you'll
get like a bunch of politicians big that
sounds really really good and so we're
going to vote on this bill rand paul
it's a bill to give us a raise thanks
rand paul for your time uh all in favor
of giving us a raise and they'll raise
their hands
and then rand is just sitting there
going like oh well some people argue
that they should be given a raise so
they won't be tools for the
multinational corporations that buy them
out i think you know the best example i
think george carlin was the one
advocating for this put advertisements
on their suits for whoever endorses them
and gives them money which they have to
wear everywhere they go i think that's
more it's a funny idea but these
companies will be like they'll have
dinner with the guy and be like look you
know here's a here's a 100 plate you
know on k street i hope you enjoy the
steak we need you to pass this bill
because it's going to be really great
for the production of our thing you know
our product and then maybe uh half a
half a million dollars might find its
way towards your super pac exactly
that's not even easier
you can have a lobbyist go and meet with
nancy pelosi somehow she ends up worth
hundreds of millions of dollars on a
congressional salary congress is allowed
to inside trade as long as there's like
a little bit of room between them and
their broker i mean the system that's
set up is is utterly absurd they're
abusing it it's just
it's so ridiculous it's such a farce
they're all taking part of it um i don't
know if you saw there was a news report
today that all of these uh congressmen
and senators are trading inside
information on pharmaceutical companies
and they're just like kind of allowed to
do it for some reason because they're
again they're the ones that make the
rules so they're never going to impose a
limit on themselves unless there's like
a giant national movement that says
enough is enough i got it i got it
you know i'm thinking about how what
would ron paul do and he's always
talking about competition i say we
create a new a second congress to
compete with the other congress and they
pass rules on each other maybe another
uh another country to compete with this
we need more competition in this country
but the only way that would work is if
there was free movement between the
other country and people could choose to
live there instead which is actually
true for a lot of countries and nobody
wants to go live there so organized
competition you know americans i mean
you can move to a lot of places and
they'll welcome you and you don't got to
do anything you just live there i know
people who just moved to mexico and
mexico is like awesome yeah great yeah
and there's a lot of expats all over
latin america who are taking advantage
of a lot of freedoms that they're
granted uh and also a lot of health care
that usually is a lot better and a lot
cheaper than it is here in the united
states especially in major urban areas
so there is a huge movement of expats
people expatriating even to puerto rico
because of the the tax liability that
they're able to get away with down in
puerto rico rather than of course uh in
the united states so there's been a huge
movement of this and i i think
it's it's only going to be kind of
exacerbated especially with countries
like mexico saying hey this this mandate
stuff is absolute nonsense we don't
believe in punishing our population we
don't believe in locking down our
population we believe in actually doing
the right thing and i think that mexico
has has really had a kind of
clear-headed approach towards this
madness that we're dealing with but but
back to this kind of hyper politization
january 6th committee meeting this is a
sign of just again the political parties
at odds with each other using dirty
tricks abusing authority because the
democrats as we talked about on the show
before their literal stance on
everything is like hey we're not donald
trump that's not a stance that's not
helping anyone that's not doing anything
that's them complaining about somebody
clarification it's not democrat
republican it's like you were saying
jordan unit party versus like populist i
guess statist versus people who believe
in freedom and i think there's a whole
bunch of status and i think that should
be the true kind of political spectrum
that we should be dealing with and
talking about rather than left and right
but one of the issues i suppose is that
the progressives are typically like like
the populist left in this country aligns
themselves more with the uniparty
so with the with the republicans you
have you got some crazy republicans you
got some weirdos but the right-wing
populists dominate the republican party
right now the left-wing populists are on
the ground begging for scraps and so
what they do is they you know they beg
hillary clinton for the endorsement they
beg joe biden and then joe biden's like
i'm gonna i'm gonna forgive student loan
debt if you vote for me and then all the
leftists and all the progressives are
like yes vote for biden then biden's
like you you dumb ass i'm not forgiving
anything yeah and now the latest news is
joe biden says he's not going to forgive
any like and we we we try to tell these
young people
idealistic starry-eyed joe biden is not
the man you think he is but they vote
for him anyway they support the
establishment they like to to defend
massive multinational corporations and
then act like they're the progressives i
got to tell you this the weirdest thing
to me is that
all of us here i'm assuming you jordan i
don't know your politics on free speech
and stuff but i think we're all to the
left of hassan [ __ ] and vosh when it
comes to social media and big tech and
corporate influences thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 pm and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time